harry enten got himself in all sorts of
trouble yesterday for pointing out the
obvious
he had a piece over at cnn pointing out
the early signs are very good for the
gop
2022. he says president trumbida's first
two and a half months in office
have been far better received than
former president donald trump's biden's
been able to maintain an approval rating
north of 50
yet a look at the data also reveals that
biden's democratic party has likely not
picked up any support since the election
if historical trends hold democrats are
likely going to face a rough political
environment in the midterms
one of the best ways to judge the
political environment is through the
generic congressional ballot
the generic ballot asks respondents some
form of the following question
if the elections for congress were held
today would you vote for the democrats
or the republicans
democrats are ahead on that measure by
about four points in the average poll
taken
since the beginning of biden's
administration that lead is about the
same as the final margin in the 2020
presidential race
and in the 2020 house popular vote
this tends to line up with what we have
seen in terms of party identification
remember the 2020 polls tended to
underestimate the republican position
which means
republicans are actually doing better on
the generic ballot now than they were
heading into the 2020 election
additionally the types of voters will be
casting a ballot in 2022
will likely be more favorably disposed
to the gop than the overall voting
population
the reason is that when there's a
democrat in the white house republicans
have a turnout advantage
a study i did back in 2018 says harry
enten who's formerly at 538
reveals that voters who turned out in
midterms with democratic presidents were
more republican-leaning than registered
voters at large in every single midterm
since 1978.
on average in these midterms the gap
between the registered voter and the
actual electorate
had been about five points more
republican among the actual electorate
just applying that shift to the polling
now it's not hard to imagine that
republicans may already have an
advantage
with the voters who will turn out next
year of course it's possible the cycle
could be different
it's likely however there will be some
movement toward the republicans in the
national political environment between
now
and next november the party not in
control of the white house has done
worse in the national house vote than
they have than they were doing on the
generic ballot at this point
in 12 of 14 midterm elections for which
we have polling
at this point the only exceptions were
when democrats already had a large lead
in 2002 when polling didn't take into
account september 11th
once you control for who controls the
white house there's a surprisingly
strong correlation between the generic
congressional ballot 19 months before
the midterm elections and the eventual
house results
if trends hold the likely national house
results in 2022 given the current
generic ballot is republicans winning by
between four
and five points so it would be a
historical anomaly for republicans not
to win back
the house in the next election cycle
right so this notion that democrats are
always and forever going to be
on the on the move here is just not true
in the same way that it was not true in
after barack obama won a sweeping
victory and you can tell the democrats
are starting to run scared here one of
the ways
you can tell the democrats are starting
to run scared is that joe biden is now
backing off
of his own push for mlb to move the
all-star games you remember he went on
espn
with the reporter sage steele and sage
asked him
about by the way she put out a tweet
saying she disagreed with him on this
so just worth noting sage steel asked
him
you know should mlb move the all-star
game he said i would i would back that
well now that stacey abrams was pointing
out to joe biden and company that you
just alienated a huge percentage of
georgians with this nonsense
now biden's trying to back off of it
according to politico
when biden was asked last week what he
thought of major league baseball moving
its all-star game
he told espn he would strongly support
them doing that
on friday the league announced it would
hold the game elsewhere and by the way
invoked biden
in their actual press release asked
during the briefing whether biden
supported the league's decision
saki re-read biden's remarks and
distanced the president from the boycott
she said
he wasn't dictating what major league
baseball should do he supports them
being able to make that decision okay
that is just revisionist history the
democrats might be starting to realize
that it's a bad idea to be this crazy
they might be beginning to realize that
there will be a backlash to all of this
and by the way the backlash
might be much stronger in terms of both
the law
and in terms of politics then anybody on
the left is willing to contemplate
one of the areas of backlash could
theoretically be
going after facebook twitter and google
justice clarence thomas had a
concurrence
in a recent supreme court case on monday
in which the supreme court vacated a
lower court ruling
in finding that president trump had
acted unconstitutionally by blocking
people on twitter
that case which the justices de moot
hinged on the idea that the donald trump
account was a public forum run by the
president of the united states
in his concurrence justice thomas agreed
with the decision to that the case was
moved because
trump is no longer president but he
argued that twitter's recent ban of
trump's account suggests
it's the platforms themselves not the
government officials on them that hold
all the power so in other words
if you are going to treat donald trump's
twitter account
as though it is a public utility you
have to treat all of twitter like it's a
public utility
thomas wrote as twitter made clear the
right to cut off speech lies most
powerfully in the hands of private
digital platforms
the extent to which that power matters
for purposes of the first amendment and
the extent to which that power could
lawfully be modified raise interesting
and important questions
thomas said some digital platforms
basically ought to be treated like
common carriers
thomas says a traditional telephone
company laid physical wires to create a
network connecting people
digital platforms lay information
infrastructure that can be controlled in
much the same way
thomas argued that while private
companies aren't subject to the first
amendment common carriers are unique
and that they don't have the right to
exclude he suggests that large tech
platforms with substantial market power
should be bound by the same restrictions
he says if the analogy between common
carriers and digital platforms is
correct
an answer may arise for dissatisfied
platform users would appreciate not
being blocked
laws that restrict the platform's right
to exclude so thomas is overtly now
stumping
for republicans to pass a law maybe with
some democrats that basically say that
twitter and facebook and google can no
longer exclude people
on the basis of political bent
thomas describes the sure scope of
facebook and google's market power
citing facebook's three billion users in
google's 90
market share in search he says it
changes nothing these platforms are not
the sole means for distributing speech
information
a person could always choose to avoid
the toll bridge or train and instead
swim the charles river or hike or hike
the oregon trail but in assessing
whether a company exercises substantial
market power
what matters is whether the alternatives
are comparable for many of today's
digital platforms
nothing is thomas said that it wouldn't
be a court that does this he said that
it would be a legislature that does this
but he says we'll soon have no choice
but to address how our legal doctrines
apply to highly concentrated privately
owned information infrastructures
such as digital platforms here's the
bottom line the backlash is coming it's
going to come strong
people on the right are not going to sit
by for this stuff they are not they're
not going to sit by
and watch joe biden unilaterally redraw
the lines of division
and demarcation between the government
and the individual they're not going to
sit by and watch social media redraw the
lines
of the first amendment they're not going
to sit by and watch democrats
redraw the nature of american freedom of
association
and freedom of speech they're not going
to do any of that and they're not going
to go along with the corporations that
go along with this there will be a
backlash the backlash is coming
and i am pleased to see that backlash
coming because nothing could be more
timely than a massive backlash against
the wild leftist overreach we are
currently seeing
facts don't care about your feelings and
it's a fact that the ben shapiro show is
the largest conservative podcast in the
nation
be sure to hit the subscribe button to
stay up to date on all of our content